con miles de coches aproximándose a la
capital que no han logrado pasar estos
manifestantes parecidos salieron a
animar bailar y apoyar al llamado convoy
de la libertad toda esta gente de todas
las regiones francesas ha sido bloqueada
fuera de parís así que nos reunimos a
pesar de ese movimiento que imita el
convoy de la libertad canadiense las
demandas de los manifestantes son
variadas desde el deseo de que el
gobierno francés suavice las
restricciones de kobe hasta la
preocupación por el aumento de los
precios de la energía movido también por
frustración hacia el gobierno
todos los países están relajando las
restricciones creo que lo peor es para
los niños
unas estimaciones de la policía las
caravanas están formadas por unos 3.000
vehículos procedentes de toda francia y
se preparan para un último tramo hacia
la capital algunos planean incluso ir a
bruselas para una convergencia europea
el lunes muchos son veteranos en este
tipo de concentraciones forman parte del
movimiento chalecos amarillos soy una
madre soltera con dos hijos y tengo que
comprar todos los días ahorrar y
escatimar para salir adelante además o
lidiar con el estrés del trabajo así
como el costo de la gasolina por miedo a
los disturbios públicos las protestas
han sido prohibidas este fin de semana
un retroceso por parte de los tribunales
el jefe de la policía de parís agradeció
el despliegue de unos 7000 agentes
durante la noche y hasta el lunes para
evitar que los convoyes bloqueen parte
de la ciudad